Overland belts and maritime roads. That's the simple way of
describing a sweeping global infrastructure campaign that seen
billions of dollars spent and hundreds of billions pledged to
invest in transport pipelines power grids and ports.
In this Bloomberg special feature we examine criticism that China's Belt
Road initiative is recalibrating political and economic
alliances and Beijing's view that it's just a means of spurring
global development and trade.
The ancient four to Piraeus is in a hurry to be the number one port in the Mediterranean and in
Europe propelling it on its journey. Its pivotal role in
China's Belt Road initiative from Greece to Germany Brussels to
London will explore the European connections in China's grand plan.
I'm Tom Mackenzie. This is Belt Road China's trade Superhighway.
Costco is one of the world's biggest shippers and port operators
and that status has put it at the forefront of the Belt Road initiative.
China has called Piraeus a dragon's head a
strategic transit hub linking maritime and overland routes .
State owned Cosco took over management of Pier 2 in 2009 under a
35 year concession pouring millions of euros into upgrading
infrastructure and building a third pier.
In 2016 Greece mired in its debt crisis sold a controlling stake in the Port
Authority to Cosco for 370 million euros and a promise to invest
at least 350 million more. Cosco cemented Piraeus  place in
Beijing's new world order. The port has been a success .
The port has been a success Bloomberg Intelligence
says Cosco was in the right place at the right time.
Piraeus handled more than 4 million 20 foot
containers or equivalent last year making it the third busiest
in the Mediterranean and number seven in Europe according to port economics
That's growth of almost 200 percent compared with a decade earlier.
The port's managing director says getting to this point hasn't been plain sailing
This year for competitive business .
Everybody has to his best that in order to win the support of
from a different carrier we get a benefit from a better world initiative.
But another financial support for sure whether we
get is because of that one bad word or the initiative will
create more trade opportunities. And this trade opportunity as
a carrier and as a terminal we win the benefit from that .
Chinese investment has supercharged parade sport but China's
clout has also raised concerns that local businesses could be squeezed out.
Almost all of the companies that goes out of small and medium enterprises
They listen to the fear.
They're afraid that these huge companies will take their business from their hands .
Business groups say initial antagonism has largely turned to
acceptance and the hunt for opportunity.
There are a lot of people that are unsatisfied because they thought we could also
exploit this court martial cause there's some people that they
blame Chinese that they took advantage of the Greek crisis .
But on the other hand we very well know that the reason is is
that they're willing to find an investment in good price you go for it
It's a catalyst it's an opportunity for all of us to start negotiating.
How will you invest by those who support. The supply chain and logistics.
are the hinterland. And hinterand is
where we can invest where we can take advantage where we
where we can use tools like creating clusters like creating
growths of volumes in order to produce wealth.
But the Belt Road fueled push of Chinese firms
across Europe has also stoked fears about
China's so-called soft power reach and geopolitical ambitions .
Chinese state owned firms now control around 10 percent of
Europe's container terminal capacity according to the International Transport Forum.
The European Commission says it
welcomes the Belt Road initiative but with caveats.
There are two major issues which we want to make sure that that happens .
All those projects financed by China and the others should
be economically and environmentally sustainable.
And the second especially of course for tender should be competitive and open for everybody .
We want to be part of this project.
But all the concrete investments must be reasonable.
And there are other concerns beyond simply how investments are implemented.
The European Union in particular is very concerned about China trying to
divide and conquer Europe through the Belt Road .
There are countries in central south Eastern Europe that are
leaning forward because they haven't recovered from the global
financial crisis and as other countries have
and they really want to take advantage of these Chinese offers
for assistance and infrastructure development .
And so it's those countries many of those countries that we see
are susceptible to receiving the benefits of the Belt Road and
then turning around and basically taking steps and actions that
support China in other venues and in political fora.
And that's where I think European leaders are growing concern.
In areas where you need unanimity voting
inside the EU
and which are sensitive to Chinese just need to own so to speak one government
out of 28 to block common resolutions on a number of areas .
What do you say to those people who are concerned that aligning
yourself so closely with Chinese state owned companies like
Costco creates a dependency for a country like Greece.
For Greece in Greece as Greece we need the investments.
We need foreign investments. This investors who they have come from China .
they are mostly welcome for me.
If they could come from Germany it would also very Welcome or United States .
Coming up we go to Germany where the CEO of Siemens tells us
why he thinks ignoring Belt road is more of a risk than getting on board.
And if you have a new initiative good or bad right or wrong
Well precieve or not which covers 70 percent of the voting population you'd better take that city's .
While Piraeus is China's main maritime link into Europe.
Duisburg port here in Germany the world's largest inland port is
central to China's overland ambitions. Every week trains loaded
with Chinese goods arrive here and they lock into a logistical
web that transports toys clothes and electronics to consumers
across the continent .
Duisburg. Network of rail and waterways made the city an inland
port. A nexus for industry. Its history is firmly planted in
coal and steel with those sectors on the decline. The CEO of
Logistics Hub Operator Do Sport is hitching his wagon to the
Belt and Road Initiative. It began with a rail link from
Hewlett Packard Manufacturing Center in China's south western city of Chongqing.
It all started at least 6 7 years ago.
The first train was a dedicated train from Hewlett Packard into Duisburg
And then we saw the chance
with respect to this time table and hub positioning are acting
from Duisburg to China and vice versa
as the distribution hub for for Europe.
Since then the value of goods going between China and Europe by rail has surged as has
the number of freight services according to the Center for
Strategic and International Studies. With the Belt Road being a major driver.
Every week about 30 trains from China arrive here Duisburg.
The Chinese want to increase that number to about 50 by 2020.
They also want to decrease the amount of time it takes.
It currently takes about 12 days to get from China to Germany.
They want to cut that down to 10 or fewer.
A fast route into Europe has become more important with the rise of
industrial production in China's south western regions.
Cities like Chongqing and Chengdu are far from shipping routes on the coast.
At the same time Duisburg seeks out projects with cities
and companies linked to the Belt Road initiative to strengthen its business
with hopes there will be knock on effects for its home city.
We have build partnerships strategic partnership
friends and with China Immersion which is one of the biggest group.
We are very close to a strategic partnership with Cosco the Cosco group.
They have all very concrete intentions and you
can imagine that part of these strategic partnership results
from involvement here in Duisburg.
You've developed this relationship with your
Chinese counterparts and that opens up
other opportunities for you right across Europe.
Our clients are global so we have to check where
we'll be the new trading
routes or how can we optimize the transportation chains.
That is the reason for instance why we are investing with the
largest logistic group in Turkey. The Arcos Group.
50 kilometre outside of Istanbul to build the airport.
Or why we are interested in and looking for a report investment in Trieste
because I think Trieste would become a very important port in the
maritime one belt one road link and then serving for the southern part of Europe.
The German Chambers of Commerce and
Industry tells Bloomberg many members see indirect advantages
from improved logisticsp owered by Belt Road initiative projects.
But only about 30 per cent see opportunities to profit
directly at this point. There's also a level of caution.
Some of our major players there are already involved but only a few
and then I have to mention also that the risk of the complains
about the bidding process and it is not yet
involved that we can say it's transparent it is inclusive it's
non discriminatory and it is respecting standards. What should
be a good standard when it comes to public procurement tenders .
Well that's interesting because in China the Chinese will stress
that this is an initiative that is open to wall that it is transparent.
But the reality on the ground is different to that
We don't have an overview. Where is the next project and where
can competitors participate. If there is the wish that all the
German companies that other European companies can participate
then we need more transparency
and we have to sit on one table in order to discuss.
Siemens is one of the major German players that have embraced the initiative.
The conglomerate generated revenue of more than
seven billion euros in China in 2017 about 9 percent of the total
And it's looking to deepen the relationship.
Like Duisburg the conglomerate is hammering out new paths for future
growth after difficult times.
The global shift to renewable energy sources means
Siemens Power Plants Equipment Unit once a
flagship has suffered a protracted slowdown.
So we have a structural challenge to master and that means you master it by innovation.
But you also mastered it by finding new ways of
doing business such as the Belt Road initiative.
We are over the almost 90 countries are being powered off and most of them
don't have a sustainable or reliable and affordable energy.
For these opportunities there .
Those with concerns about the initiative say that some of the
Chinese companies that you're potentially partnering with.
They don't have the same levels of corporate governance in terms of
standards that you do. There are concerns around transparency
the susceptibility of some of these Chinese firms to things like corruption.
Do you expose yourself to risks and is it a price worth paying essentially?
Well we obviously wouldn't
pay such a price at all because it's just a no go .
I mean if that's true for any economy in any country.
At all in this case if China wants to play an international role as the
aspiration has been announced they need to a tier to international standards
and should be any deficits do to the lack of experience how to handle it .
They've got the perfect partner with Siemens because we've
learned the hard way. But we know it now.
Do you see China as a competitor or a partner for the European economy?
Both. I think this is today's world that is not seeing either your
competitor or partner or somebody else. You can be either way
depending on what value you can create to the specific project .
China has always been a long term thinker and I believe if the
Western world doesn't get it act together on how it designs free
trade and how it interacts self in solving problems.
Maybe China just says well I've got 90 countries with 70 percent of the world's population
Maybe I just declare to be a to beat the new WTO
So you need to be very mindful about what we deal with here
because most of the economic and political power shifts go with
the amount of people in a country. And if you have an
initiative good or bad right or wrong perceived turn not
which which covers 70 percent of the global population you
better take that seriously .
If any European company can make a success of profiting from
China's Belt Road initiative it is Siemens. Infrastructure is in
the company's DNA and its ties to China run deep.
But that success will be dependent on European leaders and their ability
to persuade China to make the initiative compatible with Western
business norms. That's coming up .
For many economies and businesses across Europe the Belt Road
initiative can offer new directions for growth.
It also opens the way for Chinese companies.
However as we discover in this Bloomberg special
feature there's increasing pushback in the
corridors of power in Germany France and across the European Union.
The Greek debt crisis provided an opening for China to
Bolster its maritime links into Europe via the Pireaus port .
Winning over Europe's lawmakers though is proving more of a challenge
When the Belt Road initiative was first announced in 2013.
We saw very strong support from Europe and I think there was huge
amount of interest in how could European countries benefit.
We saw however in 2017 much of that enthusiasm began to wane.
You use doctrine constantly currently is that he has a constant
offer to China to come and join and a constant wish to come and join
offer to China to come and join and a constant wish to come and
join.
And that's even clear at the level of some member states
But on
So we set our terms at least on transparent terms.
Which is a condition that most Chinese projects accept.
those financed by EIB do not forfeit
European Commission has been working on tightening investment screening
and rolling out a coordinated approach across the block
Currently fewer than half of EU member states have rules to
allow review of foreign direct investments
While these so of priority at the moment is to make sure that all those potential projects
have a lillte playing field. That financing comes from the
normal competition like what is the case here in Europe.
But there is obviously an appetite in the European Union now for
greater oversight of Chinese investments. To what extent is
that going to impact the Belt Road initiative.
There is a rising understanding amongst our member states that as much as
we want to be open destination for friend or investments.
As we are for the most open market in the world
We must know voice investing and for what purposes.
There are also moves to reduce unanimity voting to diminish members veto
powers particularly on political and human rights issues.
We have seen efforts where China has gained strategic influence in
countries through the benefits of the Belt Road to those
countries building infrastructure and helping out with
development assistance and then using that influence to as an
advantage for China in terms of its international efforts or in
a way that helps China politically.
For example both Greece and
Hungary large recipients of Belt Road efforts by China stepped
forward to block a statement in the EU that would criticize China in the South China Sea.
The EU is also sharply aware of
China's increasing investments in the nearby Western Balkans and
Eastern Partnership countries.
It's reaching out with a trans European network
for transport done quote the European way .
Meanwhile infrastructure builders like China Communications
Construction Company and their subsidiaries are forging ahead
with deals in those regions.
In a rare interview with the Western media
organization CCC C Chairman Leo Shi Tao told
Bloomberg he sees potential in Europe despite tighter scrutiny of Chinese investments.
We have principal when
choosing investments the project must meet the highest standards
of environmental protection and bring benefit to the country's
economic and societal development and people's livelihoods .
We've gone through experiences when governments change.
They put our projects on hold and review them again as long as
they're good for the country and they're a win win.
Everyone will go ahead. Some media have different views but I think it's
because of a lack of understanding.
The European Union still hasn't officially signed
off on the Belt Road initiative.
They point to concerns around the transparency of the bidding process
around environmental issues. Are those concerns justified?
We need to promote mutual understanding and in this
respect we also need to work with companies in Western countries
including those in Europe. If we can strengthen our cooperation
I think transparency will increase. So we're working with
Europe on many projects .
I'm curious how do you respond to allegations of corruption and
fraud that have been levelled at your company and some of its
projects involved and linked to the Belt Road initiative.
We don't allow and do not have any corrupt
behaviors related to any official because we know that this kind
of corruption is not going to help with the company's sustainable development.
And as a listed company we're subject
to market supervision. If there's corrupt behavior the company
is finished on this. We are very clear .
Because critics of the Belt Road initiative still point to what
they would say is a lack of transparency around some of the projects.
What they would say is lack of hiring of local labor
versus Chinese labor. And then ultimately many of these
projects leave the country's heavily indebted to China.
That would be the criticism. There is some truth in that criticism .
On the whole I think the situation will
become more transparent as the Belt Road initiative progresses
on the issue of pushing up debt .
Some countries do have relatively higher borrowing .
I don't think that's scary as long as the country's
economy is growing enough to digest it.
It's important to see whether the
debt funded projects are good for the country's economic development
Of course, I think it's necessary for developed nations
to offer financial aid to countries that lack
development capability. As for labor currently my overseas
ratio is at least one to 10 in my company .
There's one Chinese person employed for every 10 foreigners .
The labor cost of a Chinese employee is much higher than that for a local.
Many developing countries are still catching up
and their cost of labor is lower than ours. Therefore from the
company's perspective we want to localize as much as possible
hire local people and use fewer Chinese .
I can't say there are no problems. All that we're perfect.
But the reality is it's not as people say either .
I think it's because of a lack of understanding
For both Europe and China .
the potential for business opportunities around the belt and
road initiative are significant. Yet too often a lack of
transparency is stoking concerns fueled by the fact that many of
the big Chinese companies involved are state owned .
China needs to realize that the way that it sees its belt and
road initiative is not necessarily the way other countries see
their belt and road initiative .
This is very important for China. It is now present Xi Jinping
flagship international program.
It's embedded in the Chinese constitution .
The international community I think should look at the Belt Road
initiative and figure out where countries can partner with China
where they will maintain and meet the international standards
that we hold so dearly and where they're not. We ought to be
stepping forward to put credible alternative proposals forward
that maintain those high international standards that have
transparency sustainability of projects and have the labor and
environmental standards that we care so deeply about .
Europe's leaders are trying to remain open minded about the
potential opportunities around China's Belt and Road Initiative
But it's clear that locking in full EU support will require
Beijing to translate rhetoric into reality particularly around
issues of transparency sustainability and inclusiveness.
Some European firms are hungrily eyeing dividends but those are
likely still years away. I'm Tom Mackenzie. Thanks for watching .